الوقت هو السلطه التي يخضع لها الانسان
حتى لو كان في عنان السماء داخل مركبه
فضائيه معظم الناس تهتم بالمال اكثر من
الوقت ولا يدركون ان الاخير اكبر قيمه
واهميه من الذهب النفيس فبالوقت يمكن
تقديس الاموال بينما كل ما للدنيا لا يعطي
الحق بشراء ثانيه واحده من الوقت العالم
محكوم بيوم مكون من 24 ساعه فقط لكن كيف
اذا اصبح عدد الساعات اليوم 30 ساعه بدلا
من اربع24 فكره تدعو للدهشه بعد الشيء
خاصه ان المراه معتاد على نظام حياه محدد
لكن مسيره تطور السريع في بعض بلدان
العالم تتطلب تقسيمه وقت العمل والراحه
على عدد اكبر من الساعات وهذا ما يعتبره
البعض خطوه اكثر فائده خاصه انا فكره
تقديم وتاخير الساعه ما بين الشتاء والصيف
لكسب الوقت لم تعد تلبيس
[موسيقى]
طب احنا نظامنا متعودين عليهم عايشين بيه
24 ساعه انتم جائتكم فكره 30 ساعه تصممتم
ساعه ب 30 ساعه حدثنا عن الفكره اولا وشو
الحكمه منها
واكيد الوقت مهم جدا مع الانسان وبيعيش
معه وبيموت معه الوقت اليوم
مصمم هيك ساعه
وبنعرف قديش انتم يعني الوقت فكرنا كيف
احنا ممكن حلين يا مطوع التطورات والسرعه
تحت اطار الوقت الموجود والتقسيم اللي
موجود يا اما نكبر التقسيم الموجود لحتى
يقدر الانسان يستوجبه او التطورات
الموجوده
طبعا
انت اليوم عندك 30 ساعه ما عندك 24 سنه
عشر سنوات
اذا قاعده مع شخص بتكرهيه هو دقيقه صعب
نحن عم نرجع لك الاحساس دائما انه انت
عندك في وقت هدر في عندك قصص ممكن انت
تستفادي منها
البس هسه
انا بخفف لك حدد الثواني خليتها تمشي على
مهلك شوي
[موسيقى]